this started a long time ago in a maybe
a decade far far away that that this was
just a gleam in greta's eye when she
talked to you about this yes Greta heard
that we were thinking about making
little women and she barreled into our
offices and told Denise denovi and
Robin's white quarter and I that she was
going to direct this movie and that she
would also write it now Greta had not
even made Lady Bird yet
I don't think Greta had written Lady
Bird yet and we were like okay and she
said I'm gonna go back to the novel I'm
gonna make it about women and money and
independence and and freedom and and I
have a completely different way of doing
it and we all just said okay I get it
she was so persuasive and so clear and
had the movie completely in her head
from the very first moment we met her
what was it that Greta that made you
think I'm doing this movie I'm doing it
fresh
I have something to bring out what this
story is about well for me it was it was
this incredible synchronicity of I mean
to begin with it was the book that I
grew up with it was the book that I
loved
overall books and the character of Jo
March in particular was my character but
all of the the girls they felt like my
sisters and my memories so I had it very
deep in my emotional landscape and then
and then when I was 30 I reread the book
and I couldn't believe how modern it was
and how fresh it was and how it felt
like it could have been written
yesterday and I felt like I almost had
this feeling of like has anyone ever
read this ever because why it's
incredibly weird and so I got I I was I
I thought well I think I would want to
make a movie ground
did in when they were a start when
they're adults and then I kind of had
this idea of like you know all of these
different themes and things I wanted to
do but I didn't know I I hadn't made a
movie yet alone so um anyway then I
heard an Amy Pascal was interested and I
and I did I did come in and say a bunch
of overly confident things that then I
immediately left her office and I was
like what was I thinking
but I was I'm glad that I did because
because it was something I was really
passionate about so majestic there are
things that you think you know and then
you look at them again and you realize
you'd never actually seen them in the
first place and that's how I felt about
Little Women and that's how I felt about
the significance of what Louisa May
Alcott did for my life suddenly was just
putting this clear relief and I was like
I have to give this back somehow
part of this book is about money and it
is you see at the end Jo negotiating
what's going to what she's going to get
how about the money for getting this
done Oh about the money for making the
movie yeah were you guys as tough as Jo
we had no money well yeah I mean that
what I will say is the book is about
money from the very first line of the
book which is Christmas won't be
Christmas without any presents and it's
a thread that goes all the way through
the book and it's a big theme in Louisa
May Alcott's life in the movie but we
kind of collapse Louisa May Alcott and
Jo March but Jo March she she she got
married and she had children and and
Louisa May Alcott never got married
never had children but she did keep her
copyright she was she knew to do that
and in any case this this sort of
businesswoman artist who was ahead of
everyone who was ahead of even what
narrative was allowing women to do was
fascinating to me and then of course
with movies you know it's an amazing the
meta Ness extends to discussions that
you have about how much money you get
for your movie about
girls Greta from the very beginning said
she wanted to make this movie and epic
she wanted to make because girls
deserved an epic movie about their lives
and she said I'm making it on film and I
want all the tools that all the boys get
to make their movies and then there's a
a line in the movie that Florence says
where she tells Joe that if you make
movies make books about if you tell
stories that are about whatever they're
about that makes them important even
though people might think other kinds of
stories are more important what matters
is that you make these stories and I
think that was true for Louisa May
Alcott and I certainly think that was
true for Greta Jess you went to
authentic locations they let you into
places they'd never let anybody shoot it
before so how did you balance those
considerations in the look you achieved
well I mean first of all like Greta said
she wants it I mean we went to the place
where the story was actually written
which was incredible to be able to you
know drive to work where maybe Louisa
May walked you know the streets and in
the countryside so it was not easy to do
it there but it was the right place to
be and so we just try to create this
world that you know that was this sort
of like you know epic world and was not
certainly not easy going into all of
these sensitive locations where we
couldn't you know damage anything we
couldn't make fires in the fireplace we
couldn't light candles it was like
always like a little bit of a difficult
situation going in and out of these
places but we managed to you know get in
and out of them and and you know and do
justice to the story and you know we
found a great place to build that March
house it was completely you spent what
three months building the exterior of
that yeah yeah we did we found a great
place in Concord Massachusetts probably
a ma
from there the real Orchard House which
was totally inspiring for myself and I
then I think all the actors in the movie
and we built the exterior of that house
and then we built the all the rooms on a
stage also in Massachusetts and yeah so
you know I go ahead and I talked early
about you know having this house we felt
it was like an old jewel box on the
outside and all worn in jewel box and
then when you opened it up that was full
of color and hope and and faith and you
know whatever the imagination is and
that was the inside of the house
juxtaposed to the Lawrence House which
was a big sort of mansion void of maybe
an any femininity or you know floors
sort of missing something so we created
that that whole world and that was the
main sort of like driving thing for
their production design Alexandra can
you talk about mixing up the nature the
the kind of music you used yours the
pieces by Schubert and Schumann for
example and how you struck that bright
note well the Schubert and Sherwin we're
dead at the time so well I think they
would show up to know what we discussed
about early on is what Greta just said
it the modernity of the of the book
which is I mean it yes it's set in in
the mid nineteenth century but but it
could be anytime and anywhere in the
world it could be today or tomorrow and
that was I think very inspiring we did
at some at some point think together out
loud oh good should should we use more
contemporary instruments and and it
didn't you know it felt a bit under the
nose so we we went back to stance so now
electric guitar you know something more
electronic maybe but we we thought that
we needed the organic sound
you know more ancient instruments
because there is this presence of this
19th century piano in the pianoforte
in the in the film and also even though
the film is epic and the sound had to be
epic I didn't want the score to be you
know playing huge small youth small so
the the worker is not a big Orchestra
because we're in the house a lot and I
noted about this proximity with the with
the four girls and and something that
you could really always be surrounded by
like in a bubble and remember great are
saying you know in a snowball you know
having this sensation that you are in a
warm and comfort comfortable environment
and at the same time the music follows
the the diversity of the narration which
is nonlinear and that's one of the great
idea of Creta not having this
chronological sometimes boring way of
telling a story you know luckily in some
exhibitions sometime you know when
there's a exhibition about a painter you
go from the beginnings to the end and
sometimes it's a bit boring you want to
jump from the end and back to the
beginning to understand how the link is
made and they say exactly what creator
did our thing and how did you do that
with the music it had to change course
so subtly - well yeah well the music is
also not very linear at there is some
you know unexpected changes of course or
Tempe your instrumentation just let you
feel that you're always on the move it's
not something that's safe and
comfortable like a you know a boat on
the river there's more happening it's a
bit more Rocky Florence what were your
impression was of the character you
ended up playing me I loved her I think
I'm very I think everybody is very
excited by naughty characters whether
they read them or they watch them on
screen it's very fun to watch them
want to say exactly what it is that they
are thinking because we don't do that
and so being able to play her was just
an utter delight because I just I got to
be this wild clever witty little thing
and and Greta was just so wonderful with
letting me be here it was it was pretty
blissful yeah and what about playing
with the sisters as part of that that
little Repertory sense because well I
think was so fresh was how they dealt
with each other with one another
it didn't seem like each one was waiting
her turn to give a speech they were it
was Howard Hawks it was everybody was in
there like a pillow fight that's that's
toge need to do is with Greta when I
first met her I remember Greta was
saying I want this conversation to be
quick I wanted to be like a like a sport
you should never finish your line before
someone else has started theirs and I
remember when I met Saoirse for the
first time she I was like you know you
know tell me about Greta what's what you
know what does she like and she goes oh
she's really big on dialogue and I was
like great great she was like no no no
you need to come to work knowing your
lines because she's really big on that I
was like okay and I missed as a few of
the rehearsals before the before filming
started and essentially the bit that I
missed was crucial which was that
everybody needed to be on their cues and
I remember the first day that I came to
work I realized every single line that
Greta had written that was on top of one
another
you had to come in on that exact word to
create this cacophony of noise as
opposed and that was symphonic very -
yeah and every single every single beat
was I mean Greta would come in and be
like I'm hearing this and I want to be
hearing this and you would demonstrate
what it was that you would want and
weirdly that all made sense to everyone
and so you can imagine what it was like
on the big days when they were about
eight people in and everybody had a very
specific you to come it it was like a
sport you had to have your coffee and
and be ready for the day and so then to
turn to Nick who had to put all of this
together I I won't call it flashback
because it
didn't it doesn't do justice to the
structure that this ended up having so
it had to be complex to do without
looking complex on the screen including
some of the things that Florence was
talking about about getting that that
split-second timing book just right yeah
I mean the rhythm of it was so beautiful
similar to sort of what we were doing in
Lady Bird as well just we were always
trying to find the rhythm and the sort
of the musicality of the scenes and a
good example is that scene Christmas
morning when they all come downstairs
and it is like choreography every line
has to follow to the next in rapid
motion so that the camera can pick up on
the next person and the next person the
next person it's spinning around like
snow globe as Alexander and so do you
shake it up and then you watch it all
settle and it was all perfectly
choreographed and luckily we were able
to cut it I think in a really wonderful
rhythm as well I want to thank you all
for coming in so please thank the panel